an update now to a homicide  investigation involving a two-month-old  child  this happened this morning near eastern  and saint rose parkway  32-year-old clarence martin jr was  arrested after police say he threw his  two-month-old daughter  from a second-floor apartment balcony  during a domestic disturbance  the child was taken to saint rose  hospital where she later died  police say martin then set the apartment  on fire killing the family dog  the man left the scene and got into two  car accidents while on his way to the  airport  he was taken into custody there martin  is now facing open murder  arson and animal cruelty charges